Bienvenidos a reporteros el magacín de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de Francia 24 soy herminia Fernández
comenzamos
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
muchos casos de violencia sexual han
sido reportados en Ucrania mujeres
hombres niños todos han sido víctimas el
número preciso de incidentes aún no es
conocido porque mucho de los
supervivientes no los reportan a las
autoridades sin embargo la primera dama
o Lena salesca ha declarado
recientemente que en la oficina de la
fiscalía ucraniana se están investigando
171 casos crimen de guerra crimen de
lesa humanidad genocidio probablemente
la justicia internacional tarde varios
años en tipificar estos crímenes de
violencia sexual por el momento la Unión
Europea decidió sancionar a nueve
funcionarios de altos cargos de las
fuerzas armadas de Rusia y a tres
entidades por su papel en la comisión de
violaciones y abusos de Derechos Humanos
graves particularmente de violencia
sexual y violencia de género en el
siguiente reporteros conoceremos algunas
historias de supervivientes y veremos
como una ucraniana junto a su esposo han
creado una asociación de víctimas y
además viajan por los territorios
liberados tratando de reunir más casos
aquí la historia
[Música]
una niña
estamos
hablando
[Música]
su rostro porque ya no es tan joven
porque tal vez no tiene nada que perder
pero sobre todo por todos los otros
desde el comienzo de la invasión rusa
muchos casos de violencia sexual han
sido reportados mujeres hombres niños
Cuántos son imposible saberlo
Entonces cómo encontrar a las víctimas
que guardan silencio por miedo o por
vergüenza
[Música]
Cómo incitarlos a que denuncien
Y cómo hacer justicia
[Música]
se propuso encontrar a las víctimas de
crímenes de violencia sexual y animarlas
a que hablen con las autoridades
esta ucraniana fundó una asociación para
ayudar a estas víctimas desde la
primavera ella y su esposo recorren los
territorios liberados
en esta ocasión se dirigen a la región
de gerson una ciudad ubicada en plena
zona de guerra en primera línea
[Música]
Irina y su esposo no llegan con las
manos vacías ella sabe que estas mujeres
que fueron violadas y que raramente
reciben atención médica pueden haber
contraído una enfermedad
las mujeres no hablan de eso y ni
siquiera acuden al médico
Irina antes era esteticista pero ahora
es una activista militante fue víctima
de los separatistas Pro rusos en 2014
ahora trabaja a tiempo completo para su
asociación su lucha es una manera de
tomar venganza contra sus atacantes
cuando me detuvieron me violaron con una
bolsa en la cabeza
sé que nunca podré identificar ese tipo
que nunca será castigado
si es que sigue vivo
mis sueños que esto nunca vuelva a
ocurrir a nivel mundial
con el tiempo Irina estableció una red
de contactos
le hablaron de una mujer que podría
conocer a algunas víctimas
vive aquí con su marido y un huérfano de
guerra que adoptaron
viene a hablar con usted porque usted
viaja por esta región y habla con la
gente que vive aquí seguro que tiene
contactos habrá oído cosas Me gustaría
preguntarle
sí entiendo pasaron muchas cosas por
aquí entonces la conversación da un giro
inesperado
a mí me pasó
mi marido no quiere que hable de eso
pero
nos denunciaron
nos denunciaron por haber ayudado al
ejército ucraniano
cuando llegaron pasé dos días en su
sótano al principio me electrocutaron
con algo así
no podía ver bien porque tenía la cabeza
cubierta luego me desmayé me violaron
varias veces y después me liberaron e
incluso quisieron ayudar para quitarse
la culpa
Irina descubre que está frente a una
víctima conoce bien el procedimiento
pero habló con el fiscal sin que su
marido lo supiera
solamente con el sbu solo que en el
servicio de seguridad Eso es bueno pero
la fiscalía es la que reúne las pruebas
la fiscalía es la que construye los
casos
de hecho no fui a hablar con el fiscal
porque mi marido sufre mucho por no
haber podido protegerme
por eso tampoco quise que estuviera
presente Durante este conversación
Irina volverá al día siguiente para
convencerla de que interponga una
denuncia
recurrir a las autoridades sigue siendo
una decisión difícil para las víctimas
de crímenes de violencia sexual en
Ucrania actualmente sólo 155 casos están
siendo investigados víctimas que durante
mucho tiempo y muy a menudo han sido
abandonadas a su suerte
[Aplausos]
[Música]
en el oeste del país lejos de las zonas
de combate Irina organiza una reunión
con su asociación Galina la mujer a
quien entrevistamos antes viajó 700
kilómetros para encontrarse con estas
mujeres y contarles su Calvario
unas semanas después de la violación
cuando su pueblo fue liberado pidió
ayuda médica pero en el consultorio
médico quienes la examinaron fueron
hombres de los servicios de inteligencia
ucranianos
[Música]
de ahora en adelante todo va a mejorar
todas estas mujeres que apoyan a Galina
también fueron Víctimas de violencias
sexuales desde 2014 en la región de
dumbas ocho años después Irina por fin
siente que las cosas empiezan a avanzar
no éramos muchas las que podíamos hablar
abiertamente de esto y nadie comprendía
Realmente nuestro sufrimiento
desde que comenzó la invasión a gran
escala siento que el mundo entero y las
autoridades ucranianas
por fin han empezado a creernos a creer
lo que nos pasó
Entonces qué esperanzas de que se haga
justicia tienen hoy las víctimas
la Corte Penal Internacional de la haya
abrió una investigación en marzo de 2022
que incluye acusaciones de crímenes de
violencia sexual la historia de Ilia fue
una de las que fueron presentadas como
prueba
el pasado mes de abril este ucraniano de
22 años fue violado en un puesto de
control por soldados de las fuerzas
rusas
desde que sufrió este trauma ha
intentado suicidarse varias veces
[Música]
recuerda el nombre del líder del grupo
una pista importante
cuál era su Rango daba o recibía órdenes
la respuesta a estas preguntas
determinará el resultado del proceso
judicial iniciado por su abogado
quienes dieron las órdenes podrán ser
llevados ante la haya
ante la justicia internacional
y los demás los que obedecieron la orden
cumplían
llevados ante los tribunales ucranianos
es posible que algunos de ellos estén
ahora en nuestras cárceles
Por eso tenemos que trabajar juntos para
identificar a estas personas lo antes
posible
[Música]
estoy seguro de que la Corte Penal
Internacional de la haya no guardará
silencio
no prescriben estos casos los crímenes
de guerra no prescriben
es bueno saberlo
[Música]
esta forma de violencia sexual forma
parte de una estrategia se utiliza como
arma de guerra para el abogado las
autoridades rusas necesariamente tienen
una responsabilidad
estoy seguro de que no hay ninguna orden
escrita que diga violen a los ciudadanos
ucranianos
eso sería ridículo pero de hecho eso es
lo que está en sus cabezas
Putin y las autoridades de más alto
nivel no han hecho más que echarle leña
al fuego
diciendo que Ucrania no es un estado y
que aquí hay gente mala que no merece
que sus derechos sean respetados
crimen de guerra
crimen de lesa humanidad genocidio
probablemente la justicia internacional
tarde varios años en tipificar estos
crímenes de violencia sexual en Ucrania
ya se han llevado a cabo tres juicios
sin la presencia de los soldados rusos
acusados
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
emisiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web France 24.com hasta la
próxima
[Música]